Let us consider the processing as a second example comes along.
And the red outline for this example means it is a negative example. So
now the agent will try to find a way of specializing the most general model and
generalizing the most specialized model, in order to account for
this negative example. So given this negative example, you want to
specialize the most general model so that this negative example is excluded and
yet each of the specializations is a generalization of this most specific model
because this was coming from a positive example. We do want to include this.
Let's first specialize in a way so that each specialization is a generalization
of this model. There are 4 ways of doing it because there are 4 slots here.
The first slot here deals with the name of the restaurant like Sam's or Kim's.
One specialization of this most journal concept is to put the name of an actual
restaurant there. This is generalization of this concept because this was
deferring to one specific need at Sam's, this is referring to any need at Sam's.
In a similar way I can specialize the filler of the second slot.
In short of having any meal, I can make it a breakfast meal.
This is a specialization of this most general concept that is
a generalization of this concept because this refers to breakfast at any place,
this refers to breakfast at Sam's on Friday and so on. Similarly for
the third slot and the fourth slot in this most general concept.
Now I must look at these specializations of the most general concept and
ask which one of them should I prune so as to exclude the negative example.
I notice that Sam's doesn't match Kim's, so this is already excluded in so
far as this concept is concerned. Breakfast doesn't match lunch, so
this example is already excluded as far as this concept is concerned. How about
with this concept of characterization and mix this negative example, therefore I
must floor it. So we pull away that particular concept characterization and
we are left with three specializations of the most general model.